I tell you what
Ernie when we get back to Atlanta
tomorrow I'm going to get a nice little
workout
in and then my whole night I I don't
watch pre-season or summer league That's
Just Junk in my opinion I'm going get
somewhere really comfortable tomorrow
night I want to watch the Knicks play
the Celtics first but I'm really looking
forward to watching this young man play
I think the best thing he got going for
him I think a lot of players with high
expectation get ruined CU they got crap
coaches this dude got one of the best to
ever do it in coach papovich I think
that's the best thing he got going for
him and I cannot wait I was I was going
to ask you that CH I was going to ask
all three of you guys about this fit a
19y old kid with the oldest coach in the
NBA at
74 five titles Greg Pap but he's always
you if you talk to Tony Parker job Tim
duck and he says he coach pop coach he
tches everybody out yeah exactly there's
so many coaches in college especially in
the NBA they're they're scared of
players they worried about guys
transferring or getting them fired coach
coach papit is going to teach him how to
play basketball the right way and I
can't wait to watch it and and he's
going to let him be who he is you know
goty a great Wings span on defense can
dribble can shoot the ball you know how
it is when when you come in as a rookie
a coach say don't do this don't do that
POA going to let him do does teach him
teach the guys around him I'm happy for
him because you put a guy like that in
the system dangerous player I'm not
going to put a lot of pressure on he 19s
a rookie but from the highlights and
what I've seen he's definitely in the
big man Alliance already well I I I do
and you know I never give it up that
early never zero but you don't give it
up to anybody period not anybody who was
over
68 stop go
ahead I I I I do put some weight on on
uh summer weat league I do put weight on
it in terms of I I like to go I go every
year just to see habits I want to see
your habits like what are when you're
when you need a basket where you going
to go and your 19 well we know right now
he's the best 19y old player in the
world like he is the best 19 year old in
the world however to get to the level of
what these gentlemen have done next to
me and next to you is a different it's
not a it's not always a skill set it's a
mindset can he have the mindset to be
able to come in every single night and
say I'm going to take this challenge to
be the best player on the floor and
these guys done it and so they can they
can speak to the mindset I can speak to
the skill set if a skill set if he
couples with the mindset I said it last
year three years he could be the MVP of
the league he'd be the best player in
the league because he's able to get his
shot off at
74 at any time because because he
doesn't rely on just the three he runs
the floor and he and he handles the
basketball so so when you need a basket
he can get you a basket which if you're
put the right team which pop has done
and which the San Antonio organization
has done now you have the right players
you're going to be in the conversation
for MVP every single year it'll be the
Dallas Mavericks visiting the San
Antonio Spurs and Victors in well but
under the Mind said he's got the look at
look at the maps practicing well that's
the way they play defense anyway well is
that really what sham guard is doing is
he really
that's the way the man play defense I
don't think he's trying to do that as
wiama that is something that they always
do Ernie the toughest thing for Victor's
G to be is the losing the Spurs are not
hey sham go man we know do the triing do
the triple thing man don't do that
defense thing yeah I mean the guy's you
know oh my a super athlete can I do that
he's a super athlete I can L out on the
floor no he's a super athlete Chuck I
can do that Chuck CH if you could do
that you'd still be you could do this
You' still be playing no sure did you
see him last no if you could either any
of us up here could do this we'd still
be playing well I can't do a
split I don't I wouldn't want to see you
try oh oh I I'd pay to see it I'd pay to
see it I'd pay to see it
hey
kind what the hell going on under put
that on
video hey figure out what that is